this was Kremlin theater of a formal
time-honored and reliable nature guards
in dress uniform red carpets and
Military bands the intention reassurance
the picture being painted the Russian
State strong as ever and to the
assembled Russian military who had been
notable largely for their apparent
impotence as yevgeni pregorgian's Wagner
mercenaries Advanced on Moscow at the
weekend Putin had nothing but praise
you defended the Constitutional order
lives security and freedom of our
citizens saved our motherland from
upheavals and effectively stopped a
civil war you acted clearly and
harmoniously in a difficult situation
prominent in the audience was defense
minister Sergey shoigu no sign of Putin
firing him which was one of the demands
made by pregosian during his abortive
Mutiny despite mercenary groups being
illegal under the Russian Constitution
Russia's president wants everyone to be
clear who controls who
I want everyone to know this Wagner
group was fully financed by the state I
hope that in the process none of it was
embezzled or at least nobody stole too
much but we will investigate all of this
yet these chaotic past few days have
shaken Russia and led many inside the
country and outside to question how much
Authority Vladimir Putin still wields
the White House said it informed Moscow
in real time that neither the U.S nor
NATO had any role in the failed Uprising
but Putin and Belarusian President
Alexander lukashenko who apparently
brokered the deal that de-escalated the
crisis still see the hand of the
collective West at work
foreign
we see a new wave of NATO enlargement an
unprecedented amassing of Arms by the
alliance's member states in the region
including in places close to our borders
almost daily our border guards report
various types of provocations by
neighboring countries from dumping dead
bodies to intentionally sending drones
across the border into Belarus so what
of the man who rocked Russia on its
authoritarian foundations the
belarussian government says yevgeny
pregosian is now in Belarus despite
Putin calling him a traitor the FSB has
dropped charges against him bregozian's
mercenaries meanwhile have been told
they can fight on in Ukraine as long as
they sign themselves over to the Russian
military Rory challenge Al Jazeera